une autre liste candidate justement à
plaisir mené par un conseiller municipal
d'opposition également céder à magna
t-bonds soir bonsoir
vous êtes la tête de liste d' à gauche
tout donc c'est une liste qui est
soutenu notamment par la france
insoumise le parti communiste génération
et le parti de gauche
aucune alliance d'ailleurs n'a été
envisagée avec cette candidature dont on
vient de voir le reportage qui est
soutenue elle par le parti socialiste et
europe écologie les verts ont pour ce
qui nous concerne aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans la continuité de notre
engagement de 2014 et voire même avant
donc notre démarche c'est nous est
propre
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu
véritablement de logique par rapport à
ça ne vous étiez déjà candidat vous
dites en 2014
vous aviez récolté 7 45% des suffrages
lors d'une élection municipale en un
tour puisque joséphine coleman ce berger
avait été élu dès ce premier tour vous
êtes aujourd'hui membre de l'opposition
pourquoi aller justement de nouveau dans
cette bataille des municipales
déjà parce qu'on a créé une dynamique en
son temps dans une démarche où
nous avions en face de nous battre une
droite pardon très dur mais on l'a
constaté lors dé cette mandature
et puis pourquoi continuer tout
simplement ce qui est une dynamique et
on a envie véritablement de remettre les
plaisirs mois au centre de la vie
plaisir parce que tout simplement il a
mené dans une logique où nous le savions
mais on a une approche qui est très
simple on a un socle qui se base sur une
démarche est une méthode déjà la méthode
de c'est tout simplement une approche
qui est voué à laisser parler les
plaisirs oies à s'exprimer
c'est la démocratie parti de là j'allais
dire des manguiers de participer
participative
oui par par nature mais par une
différente différents moyens vient
évidemment mais sur le principe c'est la
méthode c'est véritablement de laisser
les gens s'exprimer là aujourd'hui on
est dans une logique politique et tous
bords confondus aujourd'hui / / / /
plaisir on parle et vous parliez des des
candidats vous j'ai parlé de ce qui me
concerne aujourd'hui nous on est dans
une démarche où les plaisirs wam n'ont
pas foi aujourd'hui au chapitre on
impose des choses on fait des choses
sans que son que ce soit ça fait plaisir
c'est un centre commercial à celle
ouvert aujourd'hui tout simplement dont
je veux dire qu'il ya rien pour les
jeunes mais rien pour les tout jeunes
et puis encore moins pour les seniors
donc pourquoi continuer à tout
simplement pour faire changer les choses
c'est dans l'action que l'on peut que
que l'on s'inscrit on souhaite
véritablement changer les choses mais
retravailler la gauche peut revenir à la
tête de plaisir la ville avait déjà été
à gauche il ya plusieurs années et c'est
une ville qui à droite je le précise
depuis 2001 tout à fait tout à fait et
je ne referai pas l'histoire mais par
nature vous avez vous le savez vous
allez travailler sur vos fiches imagine
sur le principe la ville était à gauche
en 2001 et même au premier tour en
dominant c'est d'édition des problèmes
d'ego qui ont fait que la ville est
passé à droite et avec une droite dure
c'est ce que je vous disais sur le
principe on est dans une droite qui a
cassé tous les services publics qui est
cassé toute cette proximité et qui
aujourd'hui fait durant rues de lons
pâtir d'une approche artificielle et
superficiel donc vous y voilà c'est tout
tout ce qui est le lien social de cette
ville est partie quoi et donc nous dans
notre démarche c'est véritablement
remettre de l'humain au centre de tout
ça aujourd'hui on discute avec des gens
ce sont des comptables quel qu'il soit
aujourd'hui donc nous la démarche sur la
politique c'est servir les gens c'est
pas se servir des gens juste avant de
parler du reste de votre démarche on a
parlé de la démocratie locale
autre regard sur le travail qui a été
menée par la précédente majorité celle
qui est allé donc de 2014 à 2020 et qui
a été menée par la maire sortante
joséphine coleman vers du célèbre viande
importée si j'osais si j'osais je vous
dirais regarder ce qu'en dit son plus
fidèle lieutenant qui un regard qui est
beaucoup plus acérées que le nôtre nous
on a versé se voit là pour ne pas le
nommer
sur le principe nous on a une voix là
nous on a été lucide depuis le début on
a dénoncé l' approche déjà autocratique
et l'autoritarisme de madame comme anne
berger
il s'avère que ben a perdu pas mal de
ces policiers feront un tiers si je ne
m'abuse
donc voilà on a eu tort d'avoir raison
avant tout le monde sur le principe ya
aucune concertation c'est de la
communication mais de deux étages c'est
c'est durant pauline âge comme on dit
nous sur le principe la démarche allait
très simple c'est de remettre plaisir au
centre de la ville et plaisir
aujourd'hui plaisir c'est une cité
dortoir faut pas se voiler la face il ya
rien n'est fait rien n'est mis en oeuvre
et pourquoi pas ce qu'on me considère
pas de concertation sur plaisir il n'y a
aucune concertation
c'est à dire on vient saluer le plus dur
dans cette dans cette ville c'est bas de
se faire élire j'allais dire
effectivement c'est compliqué d'après
revenez au bout de six ans et puis vous
vous ne fait même pas de bilan vous ne
faites rien du tout donc la démarche
allait quand même aujourd'hui de
remettre véritablement où l on va dire
sur eux sur des ouvrages mais de manière
régulière c'est à dire on doit on doit
des comptes aux gens on doit des comptes
aux gens c'est pas un blanc-seing kindle
les autres socles de votre démarche il
ya une idée qui prévaut aussi c'est
l'écologie alors c'est une idée
traditionnellement de gauche mais qu'on
voit apparaître dans les programmes des
différents candidats sur surface
élections municipales l'écologie cette
association
les propositions l'écologie j'ai envie
de vous dire l'écologie aujourd'hui
quand j'entends que des propositions à
tout va l'écologie est au centre
véritablement
de nos vies qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
avoir comme propositions sur l'écologie
le fait de se déplacer
ddd circulation véritablement qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient à disposition des
gens je veux dire le fait de mettre
enfin en place des vraies pistes
cyclables oui la seule piste cyclable
qui lie à plaisir celle qui amène du la
base de loisirs à et qui passe par
l'égalité bruit effectivement wee cc
remettre les choses au centre les mais
l'approché écologique c'est un
raisonnement global c'est quand on
construit quelque chose c'est en tenir
compte
c'est du début à la fin c'est vous dire
c'est ccc dans le don dans la proche
c'est dans l'assiette de nos enfants
c'est dans la circulation plaisir
oiseaux c'est tout et il ya plusieurs
pleinement leur donner raison comme on
dit aujourd'hui que faire que faire déjà
réfléchir différemment
et encore une fois je reviens sur la
logique de base ce n'est pas l'argent
qui gouverne tout il ya de l'humain
autour de tout ça mais on pourra
continuer à faire en sorte que plaisir
s'étendent à tout va et que ce soit un
centre commercial encore plus grand
c'est quoi c'est de la pollution en
permanence c'est quoi comme emploi c'est
de l'emploi précaire
vous voyez vous me parler d'écologie
l'écologie s'est donné les moyens aux
gens de vivre et par exemple commercial
on précise qu'un nouveau centre
commercial un va ouvrir tout
prochainement c'est open sky sur la
commune de plaisir on a parlé de la
démocratie locale de l'écologie le
troisième socle de votre réflexion sur
la démarche c'est véritablement là quand
on parle et d'orientation c'est une et
menti de l'émancipation des gens et
l'égalité en qualité l'émancipation des
gens c'est on part du principe que les
gens sont à même de pouvoir décider pour
eux-mêmes
vous parlez de démocratie locale c'est
donner aux gens la possibilité de
s'émanciper c'est quoi c'est leur ouvrir
véritablement la vie la vie publique la
vie publique la vie politique de notre
de notre cité et qui se leurrait qu'ils
se réapproprient leur ville leur ville
et quand vous me demandez le troisième
socle et là c'est vraiment
l'émancipation des gens c'est vrai ça
c'est ça fait ça fait doux rêveur mais
je suis désolé l'utopie fait partie de
notre monde d'aujourd'hui et sur le fond
on se rend bien compte avec tous les
mouvements qui ont eu lieu ces derniers
temps les gens ont envie que ça change
ils en ont marre qu'on décide pour eux
donc nous notre démarche est
véritablement aller à la rencontre des
gens comme on l'a fait depuis le début
de notre de notre mandature savez on
continue à avoir une approche et in
accueille des gens qui est très très
très agréable pour eux parce que nous
n'avons pas fait de commentaires et de
promesses ou des choses complètement
erronée on avait mis en avant des
éléments sur notamment les emprunts
toxiques le fait que ça allait coûter 1
un freak mansart comme disait certain
aujourd'hui tout semble avait mis en
avant donc voyez on est on est lucide et
pourquoi on élucide parce qu'on est
resté il restait sur sur nos bases et on
est resté au contact des gens et je
pense que c'est ça nous l'approchons ne
parliez de nos démarches ma démarche et
conclure ce qu on arrivé là
allez on entretient ses cours mais sur
le principe notre démarche à descendre
c'est changer les choses est de changer
les choses on peut pas changer les
choses avec les personnes qui vous ont
créé des problèmes qui sont ceux de
notre ville aujourd'hui donc le
changement c'est ça on retrouve je
précise l'ensemble des agents d'adp
campagne des candidats sur notre site
internet et v60 18 points comme merci
djamel agnès maupassant en plateau
candidats à plaisir sur la liste à
gauche tout à tête de liste d' à gauche
toutes sont également en course
officiellement la maire sortante josy
fine coleman ce berger pour un troisième
mandat patrick j'enterre ancien adjoint
de la ville et annie joël prix ou admis
avec la liste taf